we are very excited to tell you guys
that we have booked a venue and we're
getting married in Hawaii on January
12th our elion deck junior and Lauren
Burnham are ready to say I do the
bachelor couple revealed details about
their upcoming nuptials during an
appearance on the view that's private
wedding so not on TV lion Dyke made
headlines after proposing to Burnham on
the bachelor after the final rose
just one day after the show aired his
brutal breakup with Becca Cochran the
more I don't know with you the more I
felt like I was losing the possibility
of maybe reconciling things with Oren
Lyons I had originally proposed to
coverin in the finale before changing
his mind weeks later to pursue a
relationship with Burnham his runner-up
communicate via cuff Rijn went on to
become the next Bachelorette her season
premieres Monday and the network has
confirmed to ET the season ends with an
engagement in March one day after their
engagement Lyon Dyke and Burnham told ET
they were ready to tie the knot but they
hadn't decided if they would be tuning
in to Becca's season I think I could
comfortably watch but I think I could
yeah and I love you in the future yeah
[Music]